AREAS. FRONT.
KICKED OUT BY DAWS.
EARLY PRESSURE IN A
MOMENT.
THE TERRIFIC PLAY.
LOOK AT WHO DIRECTED IN BETWEEN
SKATES OR JUST UNDER THE PADS TO
GET SET IF YOU IN THE FIRST SEV
DON'T KNOW HOW HE STUCK WITH
O.
SETTING UP IN FRONTT.
SEE IF ANDREW
MANGIAPANE.
HIS SECOND TWO GOAL GAME
FACING AS
BACK
HAMILTON AND
WASHINGTON.
MERCER WITH A SHOT, AND KICIC
GOOD SCORING POSITION IN THE BO.
COLEMAN IN TRANSITION.
BLAKE COLEMAN SHOOTING, AND A
SAVE BY PLAY. LINDHOLM.
AND ONE.
FLAMES TRY TO GET I
REBOUND.
HE OPENING 12
MINUTES AND 56 SECONDS. BY TRAD.
GOOD TO SEE SOME OF THOSE NAMES.
YOU LIKE TO RESET, DIDN'T
PLAY SECOND PERIOD.
HE KNO ACROSS.
RACING BACK THE OTHER
IT AT THE TOE.
RESTRICTED FREE AGENT.
TKACHUK SHOOTS, HE SCORES.
WITH DAD
5-1 LELE
SAY GOOD-BYE TO TO THE
REFS, HE CAN'T GET THAT MASK   .
TRIES TO WORK IT.
AND THEY SCORE.
A POWER PLAY G THE PUCK BACK.